Yes. Well it was.
What we tried to do was keep a change
of the drug laws on the agenda
and try and confront society
with that most unpopular fact
that it was the.
The prohibition of these substances
which were creating a great deal of the
problems that we had in this society.
It was a pretty frustrating task.
I became aware of the degree of
paranoia that exists in the town.
In this area most households
would have. One member.
Husband wife a lover.
Son
or daughter friend cousin
relative who probably use pot in
some degree and with the attention
that had been focused on them
and big raids helicopter raids
search destroy type missions
that were a regular part
of life here. People be.
Became extremely afraid
to express their opinion.
And that was probably the most significant
thing that i found was the impact
that the drug laws were
having on society in
that way people were more prepared to be.
Acquiescent about the laws rather
than to challenge them in the hope
that they wouldn't stand out.
When the. The background scenery.
And that really hasn't
changed. A great deal.
Although there are more and
more people these days.
Prepared to make a statement
publicly about the drug laws.
Are not really elected. So. Well
i in one thousand ninety one.
I stood as an independent candidate on a
drug reform ticket in the state parliament.
Who's a campaign that i
ran pretty much by myself
and it was an opportunity to
play a bit of larrikin politics.
Given that it was just really
a one person campaign.
The two and a half
thousand votes that i got.
Wasn't too bad at all and i did
indicate to some extent the.
The feeling that was here for people.
I vote i ran on a campaign of.
Voting is anonymous. Here is your
chance to put down your opinion.
And for a one one is
single issue campaign it.
It works well but the problem about it.
The problem that i see that came
as a consequence of my actions is
that it has tended to make the the
anti-drug lobby less likely to stand up
and do things. Whilst at the same time.
The negative consequences
of provisions continue.
And so they're largely
unchecked this to me is that.
Challenge of the alternative society
of the nimh and society is to somehow
or other.
Set into play the factors in society
that work towards sorting out these problems
in such a way as the community itself
and the people within the community.
Are empowered that they are able to
realise that they can effect change.
The marijuana laws seem a bit like the weak
weak chink in the armor because they're
so blatantly problematic laws their laws
that don't hold up to scrutiny in any way.
It seemed like this was a way that the
whole of society. Could be challenged.
But difficult go
and it really is difficult going on.
I ran. Yeah i.
As part of
that campaign nimbin did.
Create it's the options are
available here and him
and allowed me to campaign in pretty
many creative ways one of the ways was
the.
Advertising on television a local media
organisation offered to do ads for me.
They. Program them or arranged
for them to be programmed in.
And that was a bit of a first for.
Well it was a first for them.
And it was a first for a local
television up in this area.
Yeah not much else i can
say about it. Really.
No i don't know that there's
been marijuana campaign
or marijuana party campaigners in other
electorates another election on this
but this was the first time
that there's been a local
marijuana party type campaign run
up here. The elections were
great because they did offer
that opportunity for
the focus on an issue.
I ran a very much a sort of barefoot
politician campaign running without
a great deal of funds
and without a great deal of visible
upfront support you know terms of
people you know i had nobody
staffing polling booths.
It was very difficult to get people to
make any sort of commitment in which they
publicly committed
themselves for drug reform
or drug law reform.
You know
the degree of paranoia there
was here surprised me.
Didn't shake my faith in the.
In the nature of the name and community.
It made me aware of just the
pressures that people are under.
And made me see just how much of a
backbone marijuana is to the economy here.
And it made me realize that any
change that i did try and institute
or if i was able to be successful
in bringing about a change.
It would have severely affected
the lives of a lot of.
People so i've been caught on
that sort of dilemma between
keeping people here
in a sustainable income
and yet at the same time trying to
eliminate those negative aspects of it.
If marijuana was sold on a through a growing
cooperative basis marketed by a local
organization that did pay taxes back into
the community not back into the states
and federal communities
but back into the local community
then we'd have a lot of the
a lot of the negative effects of the
marijuana trade would be diminished a lot of
the imperatives
that are there in the marijuana trade
the need for people to earn an income.
To try
and pander to their
consumption desires the
degree of hypocrisy
that was in society kids were find it very
difficult here because they were seeing
their parents smoke and pot
selling pot in a lot of cases
and yet. Having to publicly
present a different persona.
And at the same time telling their
kids to keep away from drugs.
It only really served to
make the situation worse.
The kids were getting
into drugs marijuana.
But also alcohol and every now
and again some of the local kids would
resort to using chemical substances
but in a lot of cases.
My experience shows me
that those people who are more
inclined towards getting into.
Things like heroin those who really feel
a lot of pain in society whether that's
from broken homes from. Brutal parenting.
From being in lower
socioeconomic situations.
I don't believe that the.
That the fact that marijuana is
illegal and that people use it.
Lead people on to heroin use.
I believe that people get into heroin
use to try and eliminate the pain.
That they feel in their lives.
And just like the sly grog dealers.
And the brothels went to the
goldfields in the 1850s in ballarat
and in the goldfields other
goldfields in australia.
And preyed on the miners so
to do the heroin dealers.
Come to nimbin and.
Use the local float large
floating amount of money that's
there as a source of.
Gain for them in return for heroin.
With my own kids. Smoking
pot was one of those things
that i tried not to encourage and
it came as a bit of a shock.
The first time that i
found. My eldest daughter.
Was smoking.
And it made me realise just what my
own real aspirations for her were.
And my own. Free.
We are an attitude. I
just want my free will
and attitude was really
worse in relation to drugs.
I've subsequently modified. This
approach out of my children.
Three out of the four smoke
and basically they cope
with it reasonably well i
i myself wouldn't promote the
use of marijuana by anybody
or for anybody
but at the same time i can't
put down people who do smoke.
So i've had to take for myself.
Part of the responsibility for
setting this particular example
i've also tried to educate them into what
i consider to be an etiquette of smoking.
You don't rip off your friends
or you don't rip off anybody.
If you're going to provide
marijuana it's possible
that everyone can provided them selves.
So i've encouraged them to grow their own
to look upon it in that sacramental
way that marijuana really years.
For instance.
In traditional societies substances
that change consciousness
have always had a place
but the places been well
defined within society.
They generally have a particular
outcome their guided their the people.
Who god are experienced
over a long period of
learning in how to deal with the
effects of the consciousness changing.
Substance. What we've done in our society
is we've dropped right away from
that it's.
There's no cultural controls at all
on how the consciousness changing
drugs are used in society.
So they used randomly they use
wildly they used in a way
that is more for a particular immediate
gratification rather than seen
in the context of of growth and.
As a means of both handling society
and investigating deeper truths
that exist within society.
A lot of people do come
to nimbin with probably.
A slightly incorrect view of
what niman is going to be like
because the mainstream society generally
doesn't allow for a great deal of
interpersonal communication
randomly amongst people.
People come here looking for a section
community interaction a sense
of been important in themselves and
a lot of them don't find that here.
Ultimately it's all within themselves it's
all within ourselves this capability to
create our new society along
the way that. We want to.
We've bound so much by what's been
fed into us by society in the past.
That we are limited in what we are
able to actually achieve a lot of the
communities around here. If you view it.
Dispassionately you'll find
that they're just housing estates where
people don't necessarily have a great deal
of contact with their their neighbours
with the community they buy a share
in a lot of cases that's just a predetermined
allotment they build their houses
they build their gardens in a way that's
quite similar to the suburban dream
that has grabbed them even
though they don't realize that
when they come here they're still
bound by this suburban dream
but i really like what timothy leary said
about the decline of the flower children
the flower children may be gone but
they've spread their seeds and it's
when the seeds take root. That will see
the real flowering of the new society.
I tend to think that that that's
happening more and more i see a change.
That's coming about in a lot of the young
people particularly the young people here
in.
As they grow
and it almost parallels the
growth of the nimbin alternative
society itself at 20 years old.
All we are is a society
barely out of adolescence.
There's a lot of grown to do. There's a
lot of maturing a lot of wisdom too.
To get a lot of implementing of
what we've learnt in our society.
It's happening it's
happening all the time and.
Five years ago there was
an environment centre.
There hasn't been a lot of the organizations
rainbow power company hadn't congealed
into an actual working group.
A lot of the health networks the support
networks that exist here weren't here.
The holes that have been
built on the communities
that the community consultation processes
that have come more and more into play.
To me are evidence of the alternative
society actually getting its act together
bringing the lessons from what they've
learnt on the home communities into the
public life of nimbin now
and then is benefiting.
Substantially from the experiences of
these new settlers. But like everywhere.
Once a society starts to flourish.
You do also get an attraction by a lot
of people who see an active social
cultural life go and down.
Are visible in the streets a lifestyle
that can attract them as holding the key
to their own personal inner turmoil
but the reality still is very
much of an emerging society.
It's frustrating for a lot of people who
do come here with a lot of needs for with
a lot of the motional
needs mental disturbance.
Well look it's frustrating for a
lot of people who come here with.
Or seeking an emotional
and so to the things
that prevail within the dominant society
and they come here and find that. People
are still basically the same people.
It's like when you meet somebody famous
basically they're still the same person.
They probably got a bit of breakfast
dangling on the front of their shirt their
human i mean this is one of the lessons
that is really good to learn here that.
That if you want this ideal society you
have to sort of dredge it out from within
yourself find it find that sense
of strength and courage that
that is there. And just go for we've
got everything to lose at the moment.
Society is just hanging on the
edge and nimbin to me has
that capability to create
some state of health.
If you have your whole society affected
by disease then it means the disease
is able to grow and spread
in order to counteract
that you have to create some sort
of pocket of health that will grow
and spread affect the areas around it.
Because an immense connotations of an
alternative vision airy prophetic society.
It seems to me
that we've got the groundwork set in place
here to create some element of society
or health and from
that if we can just hang on long enough
then the change will happen we'll be able
to spread what we've learnt
out into the rest of society.
What do i currently in nor what do i hope
that they'll achieve what i when i
look at the kids around this area.
What on.
Likely to see is
or what i'm likely to see
when i look at the kids in this
area are the lessons already learnt
that we their parents took a
great deal of time to learn.
Sometimes in our thirties forties fifties.
We've still going through the
pain of experiencing things
that have been kept from
us with kids today in them
and they tend to be much more mature
experienced in a lot of the things
that were never talked about.
As part of our generation.
They seem to be able to cope
with change a lot better.
They seem to be more likely to be commune
or to be supporting of each other
they tend to go through a in a lot
of cases despair frustration.
Just like most other kids but
for the ones who grow up here.
I'm really impressed with the way
that they actually do seem to find a
path at some point which becomes really
solid.
Because it young it has
that energy that's able to achieve
things i got a great deal of hope in the
future when i look at the kids
that i've grown up with here.